جمعيات ومنظمات حقوقيه تونسيه ان تقريبا
الذي قدمته الحكومه في اطار الاستعراض
الدولي الشامل لمجلس حقوق الانسان تضمنا
عددا كبيرا من انصاف الحقائق والمغالطات
التي تهدف تعبيرها الى تقديم فكره خاطئه
عن وضعيه حقوق الانسان في البلد
فلن مشاهدينا الكرام من تونس العاصمه سيد
وحيد الفرشيشي رئيس الجمعيه التونسيه
للدفاع عن الحريات الفرديه ست وحيد
الفرشيشي اهلا بك ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا لك
على تلبيه هذه الدعوه ما هي انصاف الحقائق
هذه والمغالطات التي تضمنها وفق تعبيركم
تقرير والحكومه التونسيه امام مجلس حقوق
الانسان في جناف
اهلا وسهلا استاذ حكيم
اشباه الحقائق والمغالافات كثيره جدا
اكتفي ببعضها فقط
خصنا تقرير التونسيه التي قدمته الحكومه
عن بعد ولم تتنقل الى تقديمه بينت فيه
طبعا
في فتراتنا قبل الثوره هذا التقرير اذا
ذكرنا بالتقارير الدوريه التي كانت تقدم
الى جنيف
2008 حيث تتبرجح هذه الحكومه هنا لا يتحدث
عن الدوله التونسيه
بانها قدمت اصلاحات كثيره
واستجابت لعديد التوصيات المقدمه لها في
سنه 2017 اثناء الاستعراض الدوري
سنه 2017
الدوليه وهي مساله نعم صحيحه
هل انها فعلت هذه الاتفاقيه الدوليه التي
دقت عليها واشكر مثلا بروتوكول ما بوتو
المتعلق بحقوق النساء في افريقيا والذي لم
تفعله الدوله التونسيه الاتفاقيه
الاوروبيه حول معالجه المعطيات الشخصيه
التي صادقت عليه الدوله التونسيه ولحد
الان من 2018 لليوم لم تفعل كذلك تتبجح
بانها قامت باصلاحات تشريعيه كبرى مثل
قانون منظمه الام ضد المراه وقانون نهر كل
اشكال التمييز العنصري الا ان لدينا
القانونين وان داخل حيز النفاث في 2017
وفي 2018 لان المركز الوطني
ضد المراه لن يشتغل لحد الان الهيئه
العليا لمكافحه لم تشتغل لحد اليوم تترجح
لانها احدثت محكمه الدستوريه وهي لم تحدث
هذه الان الهيئات الدستوريه بانها يعني
صادقت على قوانينها لان نعلم ان الدستور
الجديد دستور الرئيسي
ل25 هجريا 2020 حضرتك كل المؤس الدستوريه
ولم يبكي الا على الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات والتي بموجب ما قام به من
تنقيحات لم تعد لا علياء ولا مستقله هذه
الهيئه اذا فليتعلق باشبال الحقائق اما
المغالفات الكبرى فيكتفي بذكر المغادتين
اولا بان الحكومه التونسيه في تقليدها
تقول بانها لم تعد تمارس الفحوص الشرجيه
لاثبت ملكيه الاشخاص الا اننا نعلم وانهم
من 2017 الى اليوم 10 وفي همم رقم وزاره
العدل التونسيه هناك على الاقل 2003 اشخاص
تمم مؤخرتهم على اساس 230 المجال
الجزائريه
تتعلق همم عقوبه الاعدام حيث تكون الحكومه
التونسيه لانها ستعرض هذه المساله الوطنيه
كان محاوله الغاء عقوبه الاعدام عديده هي
هذه المغلفات ان لم نقل هذه الاكاذيب في
التقدير التونسي ولكن البعض يقول لنا تونس
نجحت في الدفاع عن سجلها الحقوقي امام
مجلس حقوق الانسان في جنيفه لعل ابرز دليل
عذاب على ذلك وهذا الحضور الدولي همم
منقطع النظير في قمه الفرنكوفنيه في جزيره
جربه تونسيه وكثيرون اباتو يسالون في تونس
ما سيكون اثر استضافه البلاد لهذه القمه
بحضور عشرات الشخصيات الدوليه ما سيكون
اثر ذلك على الحقوق والحريات همم في
البلاد هل سيدفع السلطات الى تعزيزها ام
ان الاثر قد يكون عكسيا
لا اعتقد لي انه في فتره انعقاد القمه في
القنفونيه في تونس يعني كما تعلمون تم
احاله على الاقل الصحفي على اثاث في مقاله
وحاله محامي ايضا امام القضاء مرسوم
المرسوم عدد 54 هذا المرسوم
الصادر بعد صدور الدستور التونسي والذي
يجرم بصفه فضيعه وفجاه حريه الراي على
الانترنت يعني لا يمكن ان نربط بين
المسالتين ثانيا ان الدول التي شارك شاركت
في قمه في تونس
وان اغلب هذه الدول التي شارك شاركت
على تونس امام مجلس حقوق الانسان يوم
ثمانيه نوفمبر الحالي همم وذكر بانه هناك
106 10 دوله طلبت الكلمه في اليوم ثمانيه
نوفمبر عديد الدول كفونيه انتقدت الدوله
التونسيه وهنا لا اذكر فقدت الدول
فرانكفورنيا الغربيه وبالاساس فرنسا وهمم
وكان دوله ولكن ايضا الدول الكونفنيه
الافريقيه مثل تشاد ومالي وغيرها انتقدت
الحكومه التونسيه وقدمت لها عديد
الانتقادات وعديد التوصيات حتى تحسن وضعيه
حقوق الانسان
تلقى تونس ما يفوق 200 توصيه اغلبها تتعلق
بتحسين حقوق الانسان 30 فيما يتعلق بحقوق
النساء 21 توفي فيما يتعلق بوضعيه القضاء
والمجلس على القضاء 16 توفي فيما يتعلق
بالاشخاص الانسانيه غير النمطيه من
المثليين وهمم همم
فيما يتعلق ايضا بحقوق الاطفال 16 توفي
فيما يتعلق بعقوبه الاعدام وغيرها من
التوصيات الكثيره وردت على تونس من هذه
الدول انها عبرت عن موقفها في جنيف حضورها
في تونس جاء لقمه الفوقانيه وليس للتعبير
عن المساندات حقوق الانسان في تونس ونشكرك
اشكرك جزيلا شكرا على تربيه دعوتنا هذا
المساء من تونس العاصمه سيد وحيد الفرشيشي
رئيس الجمعيات التونسيه للدفاع عن الحريات
الفرديه